bienvenue king james
suire cartoon
je veux la taille des nuggets non non
non non non non
et quoi de neuf docteur ox ac à l'as mon
pote
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui t'as mal dans le monde des
toons le gars de l'ordinateur a kidnappé
mon fils
c'est quoi ce plan à la matrix
qu'avez-vous fait mon fils si tu veux
récupérer mon fils il faut que toi et
moi on fasse un petit match de basket je
veux faire un match de basket contre moi
je dois monter une équipe de chaise
stephen green je serai votre coach st
montre nous commente été
ok on la refait où vas tu ramener ton
fils je te le promets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai l'air d'un canard de lui je vous
présente
quoi
cela paraît peu probable
bloquer un canard joueurs je miserais
tout sur l'autre est payante en chef est
le king
tu vas perdre ta famille catteau ou la
vente et ma
mère ne pousse que tu es qu'inquiète
nous on est tranquille ah oui j'allais
oublier tous les toons seront est passé
alors
c'est quoi c'est être les toons
n'abandonne jamais si on doit jouer on
va les jouer
un peu d'air
tu dois gagner ce match et récupérer
notre fils
de tout
il faut entrer à nouveau jour
mayotte
la machine est en train de produire un
nombre incroyable de coyote
[Applaudissements]
ça marchait
il faut frapper fort qui font une boîte
qui choquerait tu attendais mais mais se
sert à martine moron la pause
s'éloignerait my way